les romains ont profité de cette chute
de neige exceptionnelles pour organiser
les batailles de boules de neige comme
ici sur la place saint pierre
cela faisait six ans qui n'avait pas
neigé à rome
les écoles ont été fermés une bonne
partie de la circulation automobile a
été paralysée je ne fus réveillé à 4
heures du matin 17 religieuse j'ai
regardé dehors et j'ai vu la neige était
comme une enfant tellement c'est beau en
russie le mercure est descendu jusqu'à
moins 20 degrés à moscou
ce qui n'a pas empêché ces courageux de
prendre un bain dans l'eau glacée l'eau
est très froide dit il c'est difficile
de nager pourtant maintenant je me sens
merveilleusement bien
en croatie les villes le long de
l'adriatique ont vu le mercure glisser
sous le point de congélation à
l'intérieur des terres d'importantes
chutes de neige ont enseveli route et
village natal en écho au total 1 ça
n'arrête pas dit il dès que j'ai enlevé
la neige elle tombe encore de plus belle
les autorités ont déploré de nombreuses
sorties de route qui comme ici en serbie
ont fait des victimes dans la région un
millier de soldats ont été mobilisés
pour dégager la neige dans les zones les
plus touchées
cette vague de froid ils ces chutes de
neige devraient encore durer quelques
jours sur une bonne partie de l'europe
ici frédéric nicoloff radio canada
montréal